الحكومه البريطانيه تعلن ارسال دبابات
تشالنجر ومدافع ثقيله لاوكرانيا وتبدا
حمله دوليه لدعم كياف
قصف الروسي متواصل على اوكرانيا وكيف تقول
ان موسكو الغت صفقه لتبادل الاسرى في
اللحظات الاخيره
طهران تحكم بالاعدام على ثلاثه مدنيين في
محاكمه سواريه وذوهم يؤكدونا اعترافهم تحت
التعذيب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
احييكم اهلا بكم الى هذه النشره الاخباريه
من العربيه اعلن رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشي سونيك ان بلاده سترسل دبابات ومدافع
ذاتيه الحركه لمساعده اوكرانيا في صد
الهجمات الروسيه سوناك تعهد بارسال 14
دبابه من طرازه تشالنجر 2 الى اوكرانيا
خلال اسابيع بالاضافه الى حوالي 30 مدفعا
من طراز الكبيره ذاتيه الدفاع وتبدا
المملكه المتحده في تدريب القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه على استخدام الدبابات والمدافع
في الايام المقبله بالتزامن وجه صنعك وزير
خارجيه للسفر الى واشنطن هذا الاسبوع
لمناقشه مزيدا من الدعم لاوكرانيا كم الف
وزير الدفاع بالعمل مع الاوروبيين ونيته
لبحث الامر نفسه
وفي اول تعليق الروسي على القرار
البريطاني قالت السفاره الروسيه في لندن
ان ارسال الدبابات سيطيل امل المواجهه
وسيؤدي الى وقوع مزيدا من الضحايا وانه
دليل على اشتراك لندن الواضح والمتزايد في
السراع السفاره تعتبرت ان دبابات تشارجر
اثنين من غير المرجح ان تساعد اوكرانيا في
تغيير المسار في ساحه المعركه لكنها
ستصبحوا هدفا مشروعا
للمدفعيه الروسيه
قال رئيس الوزراء الياباني
قيمه مجموعه السبع في هيروشيما في مايو
المقبل يجب ان تظهر اراده قويه لدعم
النظام الدولي وسياده القانون بعد الغزو
الروسي لاوكرانيا
بان مجموعه الدول السبع سوف تتحد وتعمل
معا لحمايه النظام الدولي القائم على
سياده القانون وفي تنسيقنا خلال فتره
الاعداد لقمه هيروشيما انصبه اهتمامنا على
العدوان الروسي على اوكرانيا
قالت الهيئه الاوكرانيا التي تتعامل مع
ملف الاسرى ان روسيا الغد في اللحظه
الاخيره امس السبت عمليه تبادل المقرره
لاسرى الحرب واجره روسيا واوكرانيا العديد
من عمليات تبادل الاسرى كان اخرها في
الثامن من يناير الجاري وشملت 100 الاسرى
من الجانبين وقالت المفوضيه الروسيه لحقوق
الانسان تتناوسكا كوفا قالت على تطبيق
تيليجرام ان الجنود الروس ابلغوا عن حاله
ابتزاز اثناء وجودهم في الاسرى لدى
اوكرانيا
وهذا خبر عاجل على شاشه العربيه مصادر
اوكرانيه تتحدث عن ارتفاع حصيله قد قتل
القذف الروسي على مبنى سكني في ديبرو الى
14 شخصا اذا ارتفاع حصيله قتل القذف
الروسي على الديبرو الى 14 شخصا حسب مصادر
اوكرانيه اذا ايضا شهدت اغلب مدن اوكرانيا
كما ذكرنا منذ قليل قصفا روسيا مكتفا
استهدف البنا التحتيه للطاقه وادخل البلاد
في الظلام مره اخرى وعلى واقع الهجمه
الروسيه اعلن رئيس الاركان الاوكراني
اسقاطه واحدا وعشرين صاروخا من اصل 33
اطلقتها روسيا على اهداف في مناطق مختلفه
اليوم وقال رئيس اركان الجيش الاوكراني ان
الصواريخ الروسيه كانت عباره عن صواريخ
كروز واخرى موجهه جو ارض الذهب الى ذلك
اعلن وزير الطاقه الاخرانيه انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي في معظم مناطق اوكرانيا بسبب
القصف وقال ابو وزير الطاقه ان روسيا
مرافق الطاقه في كاف وخد كاف ولا فيفا
وزافورينجا ومناطقه اخرى
[موسيقى]
من جهته قال الرئيس الاوكراني في بلد
ميرسيلينس كان ضربه الروسيه في محطات
الطاقه في كافه قامت الوضع السيء واشار
الى ان تسليحه اوكرانيا هو السبيل الوحيد
لوقف الهجمه الروسيه والتصدي لها
تخبرك سفارات الانذار هذه عن سلسله
انفجارات تطال العاصمه تكييف عقب ضربات
صاروخيه جديده استهدفت بمن تحتيه الرئيسيه
وفق مسؤولين اوكرانيا هذا هو الوضع هنا
اما في شرق اوكرانيا فتقف مدينه سوليدار
الصغيره بين تاكيد روسيا سيطره عليها ونفي
اوكرانيه تلك المعلومات وفي سبريسك التي
تقع على بعد 25 كيلو مترا شمال سليدار دوت
اصوات المدفعيه لتزيدما خوف السكان من ان
تكون الهدف الثاني اما في منطقه الشركسي
فتعيشه هي الاخرى على واقع تحذير حاكم
المنطقه من احتمال وقوعه هجوم صاروخين
روسي كبير
الهجمات الروسيه طالت ميكو لايف حيث تم
استهدافها بسبعه عشره قاذفه روسيه حسبما
افاد حاكم المنطقه في ما تعرضت منطقه
خارجيه في شمال الشرقيه ايضا له صاروخيه
الضربات الروسيه استهدفت كذلك منشات حيويه
في الفيف وفق مسؤولين اوكرانيا كما سجلت
هجمات في الجنوب الاوكرانيه في المنطقه ذا
بوريجيا
نيران الحرب في اوكرانيا تشتد اشتعالا
يوما بعد يوما هجوم تلو الاخر فيما تحاول
روسيا ومن خلال تسانتها الحربيه فرض
سيطرتها على مناطق جديده وتضييق الخناق
على العاصمه
الى الشان الايرانيه الان حكم قضاء النظام
الايراني في القضيه الغامضه المعروفه باسم
بيت اصفهان على ثلاثه مواطنين هم صالح من
الهاشمي مجدي يعقوب وسعيد كاظمي حكمت
عليهم بالاعدام كما حكم
26 سنه
واتهم لاعب كره القدم السابق بالعضويه في
تجمعات غير قانونيه بهدف الاخلال بامن
البلاد
وعقدت جلسات المحاكمه لهؤلاء المتظاهرين
الذين تقل اعمارهم عن اربعين عاما خلف
ابواب مغلقه كما لم يتم نشرو اي معلومات
عنهن
[موسيقى]
اعلنها وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه
ان بريطانيا من ايران مؤقتا احتجاجا على
اعدامي علي رضا اكبر
على المدعي العام الايراني
من تنفيذ حكم الاعدام كما شدد كلافريا على
ان بريطانيا عزيمه على محاسبه النظام
الايراني بسبب انتهاكاته المروعه لحقوق
الانسان
وقفي مزيد من ردود الفعل الدوليه قال وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني بلينكن ان
بلاده تقف بحزم الى جانب المملكه المتحده
في ادانه ايران بشده لاعدام الايراني
البريطاني مزدوج الجنسيه علي رضا اكباري
لكن قال انه يحمل ايران المسؤوليه عن
محاكماتها الصوريه وعمليات الاعدام
المسيسات من جهته قال الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون وان اكبري انضم الى قائمه
طويله للغايه لضحايا القمع وعقوبه الاعدام
في ايران معربنا عن تضمنه مع بريطانيا
والشعب الايراني في مواجهه قمع النظام
الايراني اما وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
فقد وصفت اعدامها اكبر بانه اجراء غير
انسانيه اخر من النظام الايراني مؤكده ان
بلادها ستقف الى جانب اصدقاءها لبريطانيين
لاتخاذ اجراءات ضد النظام الايراني
رغم الدعوات المتكرره من قبل الخارجيه
البريطانيه الى عدم اعدام علي اكبري مضت
ايران قدوما باعدام المواطن الايراني
البريطاني بعد ثلاثه اعوام من اعتقاله وهو
ما اثار حمله تمديد حكوميه واسعه حذرت من
ان الاعدام لن يمر الكرام اولى الخطوات
المتخذه فرض عقوبات على المدعي العام
الايراني
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سوناك اعتبر
ان الاعدام عمل قاسم وجبان نفذه نظام همجي
لا يحترم حقوق الانسان في معتبره وزير
الخارجيه انا اعدام اكبر في ايران يستحق
الادانه بكل العبارات ادانه بدا يتساءل
الكثيرون عن شكل تنفيذها من قبل الحكومه
البريطانيه حيث دعى نواب الى ضروره اخذ
موقف اكثر حزما لحمايه المواطنين
البريطانيين مزدوجين الجنسيه فيما دعى
نواب الى ضروره اتخاذ خطوات تعكس مدى
الاستياء من التهديدات الايرانيه التي
طالت مقيمين في بريطانيا وهو بدا في
عبريطانيا الى دراسه قرار ادراج الحرس
الثوري الايراني على قائمه الارهاب قرار
قد يصبح اكثر الحاحا مع تنفيذ عمليه
الاعدام بحق اكبر
اهتماما عالميا واسعا حرم منه العشرات من
الايرانيين الذين ينتظرون تنفيذ حكم
الاعدام بحقهم بسبب مشاركتهم في المظاهرات
وهو ما جعل توقيت اعدام اكبر يزيد من نبره
التنديد البريطانيه بتحركات الايرانيه هنا
من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
محمد جعفر منتظري ساهم في التنظيم القضائي
داخل الحرس الثوري الايراني
اعتبر اعدامات الثمانينات مفخره للقضاء
الايراني
انتقد وزير الاتصالات لفشله في السيطره
على الفضاء الالكتروني خلال الاحتجاجات
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الاسبق لمحكمه العدل الاداري
والمحكمه الدينيه
يقف وراء اصدار احكام الاعدام ضد المحتجين
والمصادقه عليها
المجتمع الدولي يقول ان منتظري يقول
محاكمات سوريه غير متوافقه مع القوانين
في ابريل 2016 عينه منتظري مدعيا عاما
لايران
في ديسمبر 2022
واشنطن تفرض عقوبات على منتظر لدوره في
الاعدامات
في يناير
2023 بريطانيا تفرض عقوبات على منتظر
لدوره في اعدام علي اكبري
بعد الفاصل
قبيله جلسه مجلس الامن وزير الخارجيه
اليمنيه ذو الاتخاد مواقف دوليه اكثر
سراما تجاه الحوثيين
اهلا بكم من جديد جدد وزير الخارجيه
اليمني احمد عوض بن مبارك التحذيره من
الخطر الذي يشكله الحوثيون على اليمن
الدولي لعقد جلسه المغلقه بشان اليمن غدا
الاثنين
واسيستمعوا المجلس لاحاطه من المبعوث
الاميه حول اخر تطورات فيما يتعلق
بالمساعد لتجديد الهدنه المنقضيه وتوسيعها
واشار بن مبارك الى ان مجلس القياده
الرئاسي على تحقيق السلام واستعاده الامن
والاستقرار في اليمن الا ان عدم وجود
شريكان يؤمن بالسلامه جميع الجهود واضاف
الوزير اليمني انا طبيعه العدوانيه
في اليمن
كما حمل بن مبارك
معالجه قضيه خزان متحرك صفر
اكد المتحدث باسم الرئاسه التركيه ابراهيم
كالين ان شان عمليه عسكريه بريه في سوريا
ممكن في اي وقت وقال كان ان بلاده تواصل
دعم العمليه السياسيه التي بدات نهايه
سبتمبر بل ديسمبر مع لقائه وزيري الدفاع
التركي والسوري في موسكو لكن شو نعمل
عمليه بريه يبقى ممكنا في اي وقت بناء على
مستوى التهديدات الوارده
الى اخبار الرياضه في التقرير التالي
والامطار اليوم نحو استاد الملك فهد في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياضي لمتابعه مباراه
ريال مدريد وبرشلونه في نهائي كاس السوبر
الاسباني
فاز برايتون على ضيفه ليفربول بثلاثه
اهداف دون رد ضمن مباريات الدوري
الانجليزي لكره القدم
يتجدد الصراع اليوم بين ارسنال وتوتنهام
حين يلتقيان في درب شمال لندن ضمن منافسات
الدوري الانجليزي
حفظ النصر على صدرته لترتيب الدوري
السعودي عقب تعادله دون اهداف مع مضيفه
الشباب
تغلب الجيش الملكي على اولمبيك خريبكه
بهدفين دون رد ضمن منافسات الدوري المغربي
وفي البطوله نفسها فاز الرجاء البيضاوي
على مضيفه نهضه بركان بهدفين دون رد
رحبت منظمه الصحه العالميه بنش بكين
بيانات جديده حول الوضع الوبائي المتعلق
بفيروس كورونا لكنها طلبت مزيدا من
التفاصيل حول انتشار المرض في مقاطعهم
المنظمه قالت ان مديرها العام تدرس اذانهم
اكد مجددا اهميه المزيد من التعاون
والشفافيه من جانب الصين الصحه العالميه
قالت انها بصدري تحليل المعطيات التي تغطي
هذه الفتره التي تسمح بفهم افضل للوضع
الوبائي وتداعيات هذه الموجه على الصين
الصحه العالميه قالت انها بصدد تحليل
المعطيات التي تغطي فتره الاخيره والتي
تسمح بفهم الافضل للوضع الوبائي وتداعيات
هذه الموجه على الصين وكان في الصين اعلنت
امس السبت انها سجلت على الاقل 60 الف
ووفات على صله بالفايروس بين الثامن من
ديسمبر والثاني عشر من يناير
بياناتنا انه في الفتره من 8
عام 2022 الى 12 من يناير 2023
حدثت
59,938 حاله وفاه مرتبطه بفايروس كورونا
في المؤسسات الطبيه في جميع انحاء البلاد
من بينها كانت
553 حالات وفاه بسبب فشل الجهاز التنفسي
الناجم عن الاصابه بالفايروس واربعه
وخمسون الفا
435 حاله وفاه ناجمه عن الامراض الكامنه
الى جانب فيروس كورونا
تظاهره قرابه المئه الف اسرائيلي في ثلاث
مدن الرئيسيه امس السبت احتجاجا على خطط
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتانيا هو للاصلاح
القضائي واتهمه المنظم مناب بتقويض الحكم
الديمقراطي
ل بحيث نرى عشرات الالاف من الاسرائيليين
قد نزلوا الى الشارع حيث يتظاهرون ضد ما
يصفونه بانقلاب حكومه اليمين على النظام
السياسي والقضائي في اسرائيل يسعى نتانيا
الى تمرير مشروع قانون لتوسيع لجنه اختيار
قضاه المحكمه العليا على ان يكون سبعه
منهم من تعيين الحكومه الامر الذي يعطيها
اغلبيه تلقائيه مطلقه وهو ما وصفه
المتظاهرون بالانقلاب
المظاهر المناهضه لحكومه تحت عنوان نقاتل
من اجل الديمقراطيه وسطها انتشار واسع
للشرطه الاسرائيليه في ظل تعليمات من وزير
الامن القومي المتطرف تمر بني كبير
بالتعامل بقوه مع متظاهرين اليسار
والمعارضه وقد يكون النزول الى الشارع
بدايه مواجهه بين المعسكريين وسط تحذير
بعض الاسرائيليين من خطر نشوب حرب اهليه
لا ناكل غاصب من تل ابيب العربيه
[موسيقى]
اعلن البيت الابيض العثور على خمسه صفحات
اضافيه من الوثائق السريه في مقر اقامه
بايضا الشخصيه في ولايه تلاوه وتحديدا في
مكتبته الخاصه
وتضمنت المواد السريه التي تم العثور
عليها ملفات تحمل تصنيف سري للغايه وتضم
معلومات حساسه مع الحصول عليها من المصادر
الاستخباراتيه حسب مصادر لسي ان ان هو
تعلقت مواضيع الوثائق السريه للمذكرات حول
اوكرانيا وايران وبريطانيا
اثارت وثيقه تورس التي عثرت عليها الشرطه
الفيدراليه في منزل المسؤول عن الامن في
العاصمه البرازيليه اندرسون تورس سيجالات
كثيره كونها تضمنت تدبير الطارئه للانقلاب
على نتيجه الانتخابات الرئاسيه الاخيره هو
التورث في احداث الشغب
تداعيته اعمال الشغب الاخيره لا تزال تخيم
على المشهد الامني في البرازيل فيما اشعلت
وثيقه توريس الازمه في البلاد
التحقيقات بدا التكشف عن تورط اي شخصيات
مهمه من بينهم اندرس
المسؤول عن الامن في العاصمه البرازيليه
ما ان امرت المحكمه العليا باعتقال توريس
بتهمه التقصير في اداء واجبه حتى عذرت
الشرطه الفيدراليه في منزل الرجل على
مشروع مرسوم رئاسي يكشف ادله مثيره للجدل
فماذا فضحت تلك المسوده تدابير طارئه
للانقلاب على نتيجه الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التي فاز بها الرئيس البرازيلي لويس اناثي
سيلفا تورطه وزير العدل والامن العام في
عهد الرئيس البرازيلي السابق جانيير بور
سينارو باحداث اقتحام المقرات الحكوميه
تحمل سيناريو مسؤوليه تخريب المؤسسات
الحكوميه من قبل انصاره الى جانب تسهيل
عناصر من قوات الامن المواليه لبورسونارو
دخول المخربين الى المؤسسات الحكوميه
وثيقه تحمل الكثير لكن توريس نفى ما جاء
فيها ونفى ايضا تورطه في اعمال شغب
الاخيره متهما الشرطه بتسريب محتوى
المسوده عن قصد ومع عوده الامن وان كان
بشكل تدريجي يقول خبراء في القوات المسلحه
والمنتدى البرازيلي للامن ان لولا بحاجه
الى وزير دفاع قوي لمواجهه ايدولوجيه
بورسونارو داخل المقرات الامنيه والقوات
المسلحه وتغييرها بالكامل جاسم محسن
العربيه
شهدت ولايتكاليفورنيا مزيدا من العواصف
والامطار والثلوج ما اثار مخاوف من حدوث
فيضانات كما تسببت الامطار في انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي واسفرت عن مقتل مالا يقل
عن 19 شخصا
[موسيقى]
يتابعوا اقرباء التوام السيامي عمر وعلي
بشكل يومي تطور الحاله الصحيه لهم بعد
اجراء عمليه الناجحه لفصل التوام في
الرياض اجواء من الفرح تغمر القريه التي
يقطنونها جنوب بغداد
هنا في قريه البصالح بمنطقه اليوسفيه جنوب
بغداد يقع منزل التوام السيامي عمر وعلي
اللذين اجريت لهما عمليه جراحيه استغرقت
11 ساعه حبس معها سكان القريه انفسهم وهم
يتابعون اولا باول تفاصيل العمليه التي
اجريت في مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي
للاطفال في السعوديه
نجاح العمليه
فاقت الفرحه في ابناء عمومته والمنطقه وكل
الشعب العراقي فرحه ما مثلها فرحه هاي
العمليه انطتهم الحياه جديده العمر وعلي
العمليه لكن
الحياه بس الحمد لله والشكر وفضل الله
وفضل الفريق الطبي اللي تم هذه العمليه
بنجاح وان شاء الله صارت لهم حياه جديده
اكثر من ثمانيه اشهر من بعد ولادتهما
قضاها هذا التوام السيامي هنا قبل نقلهما
الى الرياض لاجراء واحده من اكثر العمليات
تعقيدا لفصل التوائم في العالم
على مساعدتهم ان اللي هم ساهموا باخراج
التوام
من العراق الى الرياض ونجاح هذه العمليه
بالنسبه
للطفلين السيامي علي وعمر وعادتهم الى
الحياه من جديد اجواء الفرح هناك عمه هذه
القريه التي تنتظر بفارغ الصبر عوده
التوام السيامي عمر وعلي من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بعد نجاح عمليه فصلهما
ومنحهما حياه جديده من اليوسفيه جنوب
بغداد منتظر رشيد العربيه
ختم من نذكر بالعناوين
الحكومه البريطانيه تعلن ارسال دبابات
تشالنجر ومدافع ثقيله لاوكرانيا وتبدا
حمله دوليه لدعمك
انيا الاخيره
الف مبروك
في محاكمه صوريه وادوهم يؤكدونا اعترافهم
تحت التعذيب
اشكركم طيب المتابعه التقيكم بعد قليل في
نشر اخباريه جديده ابقوا معنا في امان
الله
[موسيقى]